[THEME MUSIC]
BRANDON BAKER: All
right, good afternoon.
Welcome, everyone,
to Security 300.
This talk's going to be about
how Google's infrastructure
helps enable us to quickly
respond to incidents, things
like Meltdown and Spectre.
I'm Brandon Baker.
I'm tech lead for cloud
security at Google.
I'm responsible for the security
of our cloud infrastructure
and of the security services
that we run on top of cloud.
I'll be co-presenting
today with Andy Chang.
ANDY CHANG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Andy Chang one of
the product managers
on Google Security team.
And so we're very excited
to be able to share with you
how Google's
Security architecture
and infrastructure, including
the technology, the people,
and process, allow us
to address at scale
instances of this type.
Whether they're at the scale
and severity of something
like Spectre or Meltdown, which
were fundamental flaws that
were found in most
microprocessors today
and which impacted the
entire industry, or whether,
in another example,
they're a targeted attack
on a specific Google service.
In both cases, the
infrastructure security
design that we have has
enabled us to respond to these
and mitigate these
without any impact
to customers and without
any effort from customers.
So today, what we'll cover is
really set up in five stages.
I'll talk about the overview
of Google Security Approach.
I'll also talk and highlight
some of the key technologies
and then turn it over
to Brandon to go deep
on both Spectre and Meltdown.
And we'll take a trip in the
Wayback Machine, back to 2014,
and talk about an App
Engine breakout attempt.
We'll then close with a summary
of really the different things
that are in play across
technology, process,
and people, which again, enable
us to respond to these things
without impacting customers
and without any effort
from customers.
So first, to emphasize that
in both of these incidents,
these were mitigated by Google
and Google teams without,
actually, any impact on
customers, their data,
or on Google or Google's data.
And so no data was harmed in
the creation of these events.
So at Google, we really think
about security in five pillars,
and we focus product design,
technology, people, and process
around these five pillars.
The first of these is really
around Platform Trust,
the core technologies
that really--
that we create to
drive security,
protection, monitoring,
identification
within the platform,
and this will
be the focus of most of the
technology piece of this talk.
In addition, we have
technology and products
focused around the full
lifecycle of data, not just
in data protection-- so
collection, discovery, consent,
access, protection, wipeout,
takeout, that full lifecycle.
In addition, we
also have technology
focused around policy and
control and identity and access
management to allow us first
to specify what we think
is the proper behavior, and
then to detect and enforce
on those behaviors,
as well as for us
to have your identity
be a key thing that
defines what you have access
to and what you authorize on.
In addition, we have a
fourth pillar focused
around application security.
So that's really around
the different pieces that
allow both the
applications we built,
as well as the applications
you build on our platform,
to stay secure, again, from both
visibility, controllability,
protection,
detection standpoint.
And then lastly,
the fifth pillar
that we focus and build process
technology and people skills
around is around our
operations and risk management.
How do we actually
operate the platform,
and how do we operate
the infrastructure
that you guys develop on for
success and for security?
The bulk of this
talk will be focused
on really three of these.
The platform trust pieces
and underlying technologies
form the majority
of how we address
both Spectre and
Meltdown instance,
as well as the attempted App
Engine breakout in addition
to application security
and then the people
in process and operations.
For those of you who've
attended previous Google
Talks at Next or other talks
around our infrastructure,
this diagram is probably
fairly familiar with you.
We think about the
security stack at Google
really in nine layers.
And the core
philosophy of Google
has always been "Defense in
depth, at scale by default."
In other talks, previously we've
gone through each of these nine
layers.
And the thing to take
home today from this
is that both horizontally
within a layer,
we have multiple
layers of protection
so that there's no
single point of failure.
And then across each stack
layer as you go up and down
the stack, we have
multiple layers again
that prevent you from having
one single point of failure.
For this talk, we're going to
focus on really three areas.
First, around our Hypervisor,
and the curated OS images.
In addition, we're going to
talk about live migration
as one of the key ways
we did at-scale patching.
And then finally, we're
going to talk about how
both from a process and
technology standpoint,
our teams do instant response
forensics, as well as
the sandboxing
technology that protects
a lot of our applications.
For the balance of
this talk, we'll
be again, as I said, focused
on technology, process,
and people.
So those color codes--
you'll see those in the
upper left hand of each slide
when it's relevant,
so focus in on that.
And that will be true for
all three of the main topics
we're covering.
As a preview of some
of the things Brandon's
going into much
more detail about,
we will be talking about our
purpose-built Hypervisor,
operating system, and
the application pieces,
around really the
containerization that's
core to a lot of how
we deliver services,
as I think Diane talked
about in the keynote.
And really, the
consistency and homogeneity
of our underlying
infrastructure,
which enables the
next two items--
the ability for us to do live
migration, the ability for us
to do continuous patching.
We'll also be talking
about sandboxing technology
in general that we
apply to provide
multiple boundaries of
security for applications,
as well as our gVisor sandbox,
which we open sourced back
in May.
As I think Dianne
highlighted in the keynote,
Google loves containers.
We run a lot of things within
containers, including our VMs--
including everything in GCP.
Containers really give us
that abstraction boundary
and importantly, an isolation
boundary for resources,
for execution--
also for us to manage the
quality of service on CPUs.
To give you a sense of
context around this,
when you run a
service on GCP, you're
really running a service
within a container that's
running on an guest OS that's
within another container that
runs on our host OS.
As I think we highlighted
in the morning
again, on a weekly
basis, we start over
four billion containers.
So with that, I'm going
to transition over
to Brandon, who's going to
talk to you a lot more in-depth
about both the two instances
that we're talking about today.
BRANDON BAKER: Thank you, Andy.
So how many of you here
remember hearing about Spectre
and Meltdown back in January?
Right.
It's a pretty
fundamental discovery,
and what made it so
interesting and so unique
was that side channels
as a vulnerability class
had been known for a while.
There was research in the
early 2000s that said look,
if you have a crypto algorithm
and it accesses memory
in a certain pattern based
on bits being in a key,
you could use that
to derive information
about that program's behavior.
What was different with Spectre
and Meltdown was a realization
that most modern
CPUs are constantly
running a speculative engine--
another set of
programs, basically,
that you don't
have control over,
which are racing
ahead and trying
to fetch memory that might
be useful to the real program
when it gets around later.
And it'll do things like try
to speculate and estimate
which branches might
get taken, and what
interesting memory, then,
is useful to try to pull in.
And it's this
speculative behavior
that turns out actually
leaks a lot of information--
a lot more than anyone
really realized.
So much so, actually,
that you can read out
the entire contents of memory
from an unprivileged domain,
whether it be user space
process or a virtual machine.
And what this had
is the potential
for an impact to
affect how VMs could
be isolated from each other.
Or how a process could be
isolated from its operating
system.
Or how a JavaScript applet could
be isolated from the browser
that it's running.
So with this
discovery in mind, I
want to take you through a
little bit of an inside look
of what this looked like at
Google in responding to this,
with a focus around Cloud, but
also a realization that this
affected and impacted
the entire industry.
So we'll start the wayback
machine here, back to June
last summer, when Project
0 discovered this issue.
There was a period of time, then
we transition from July time
frame, where with this as a
discovery and a realization,
how are we going to fix this?
How could we actually
respond to this?
This is a fairly fundamental
flaw in modern CPUs
that we all depend on.
We needed to respond, though,
because the potential impact
to the industry was too great.
But we also had to develop
mitigations and workarounds
in such a way that didn't
really impact performance.
That was a very
important element
to all the consideration
I think you
were doing in this time frame.
Did the fix have to
come from microcode?
Did it have to
come from hardware?
Did if have to
come from software?
Were there things we
could do in the compiler?
This is this time frame
where a lot of experts
from a wide variety of
disciplines and fields
came together and spent the
time to think through this.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about what those mitigations
were, and why they
were effective,
and how we got those
out into production.
Because deployment obviously is
a very serious consideration.
This was a set of
flaws that we had
to basically patch every
machine at Google to address.
And then it moves forward
to this last period
of time frame for disclosure.
Coordinated responsible
disclosure--
super important, given
the wide impact of this
affecting the entire industry.
And I have to say, as we were
going through this time frame,
every day, every week, was
always this concern around,
was this going to be leaked?
Was somebody going to
also co-discover this?
There was a security
researcher in July
who made a really, really
close discovery of something
very similar to this
set of problems,
but couldn't quite get the
implementation details working
and quite right.
And so there was
a brief kind of--
OK-- can pause and
get back into this.
Because it was important that
we also made sure that not just
Google, but the
whole industry was
ready to go when it was
time to announce this issue.
And as part of that thinking
through this timeline of--
OK, where are people thinking
about side channel attacks--
speculative execution?
How much interest
is there going on?
Is there awareness
of this issue--
thinking through this trend?
And amazingly, we were
actually able to keep this
as a coordinated disclosure.
And really, it wasn't
until January 3
when this actually
came to light--
mostly to plan.
So I'm going to talk
about some of the details,
kind of a refresher or
maybe sort of a deeper dive
into how this thing
actually works
and what the variants were.
There are many
variants of this class.
Because in some sense, this is
a new class of vulnerabilities.
And at the time, the June
discoveries of last year--
the ones we were dealing
with responding to--
these were the three variants
that we were looking at.
And I want to call
these out to you
because each one required
a different mitigation
and a different
part of our stack.
So the first variant
here is something
we call Bounds Checks Bypass.
I mentioned there's that
speculative engine that's
always racing ahead.
It skips a lot of
important checks--
things that normal software,
when it actually really
does finally execute, will do.
For example, check
within the bounds arrays,
or within limits, or greater
than/less than checks.
Those are checks that the
speculative engine simply
doesn't bother with, because
it's just trying to race ahead
and be useful to fetch as much
memory as it can ahead of time.
Well, it turns out that that's
actually a pretty useful thing,
then, to then find
interesting code gadgets where
you can induce the speculative
engine to race ahead--
read and touch a
bunch of memory,
and then affect the
subsequent behavior
of the speculative engine.
And it's that chaining
of those events that
actually leaks information.
The second variant--
Branch Target Injection.
This is also another behavior
that the speculative engine
does.
When it encounters a
branch, it has to decide--
OK, what's most
likely to happen here?
Am I most likely to
expect the branch
will be taken or not taken?
And it turns out you actually
can either find or introduce
or inject interesting branch
target gadgets into the address
space of the thing that you
want to try to leak information
out-- say it's the
kernel or a Hypervisor--
and use those to sort of, again,
watch and steer that behavior,
watch the pattern
of memory that's
accessed, and then
from your own domain,
time how your memory
accesses work.
And that actually again ends
up leaking bits of information
at a time.
Repeat that a few
million billion times,
and you've read out the
memory of the machine.
And the last category--
Meltdown.
Given a slightly different name.
Given that its behavior
is a little bit different.
I mentioned these other
ones are more sort
of a speculative behavior, and
branching, and touching memory.
Meltdown was different
in that it's basically
just a fundamental
privilege check
that the speculative pipeline
doesn't bother to do until it's
all done with speculation.
And this is the user kernel
supervisor page table bit.
And what this means is actually
the speculative engine, when
you're in a user mode process,
will happily go and read
right on through into kernel
memory in the same address
space--
something that's normally
prohibited and would
generate a page fault.
Speculative engine
doesn't check that bit
until the very, very
end of the speculation.
Again, on some processors.
And again, what that means is
you can effectively then induce
the speculative
engine to read memory
that your program should never
normally be able to read--
time access patterns
leak information out.
So with the ideas
here of these issues,
I'm going to take a
step back for a moment
and talk a little bit about
our infrastructure stack
and some of the
security philosophy
that we have at Google.
One of our fundamental guiding
principles here at Google
is a two security boundary rule.
And what that means
is that we always
want to ensure and
engineer into our systems
at least two distinct security
boundaries, such that no one
single flaw can allow
malicious code-- hostile code--
to break out.
And in the case for Google
Compute Engine, which
underpins a lot of our
Cloud infrastructure,
including Kubernetes engine
and many other things,
those two boundaries
happen to be these two
pieces of software here--
KVM and VMM-- our
purpose-built VMM.
And I'll talk a little bit
about what each of those are,
and how they compose
in the stack,
and what the security
properties of them
are, and then how
and where are we
had to apply these
mitigations on top of them.
All right.
So what is KVM?
KVM is the hypervisor that's
part of the Linux Kernel.
This is what the majority of
our structure is based on,
and it's open source.
Google has invested quite a
lot into finding and fixing
vulnerabilities in KVM and
getting those vulnerabilities
patched and pushed upstream.
We've also invested
a significant amount
in reducing the attack
surface in KVM--
reducing complexity,
taking devices out of KVM
into the host kernel and
pushing them up into user space
where they can be further
and better sandboxed
in that user space VMM.
And so the investment
here is to ensure
this is a primary
security boundary,
and as hardened and as
minimized as possible.
But yet still,
something like Spectre
means that if there is a
vulnerable branch target
inside of KVM, a virtual
machine could potentially
read the memory of the
entire host machine.
It's a significant concern.
And then up in this
user space portion
is a purpose built
Virtual Machine
Manager that Google built. And
why we went with this approach?
Well, we wanted something
that was really small
in attack surface.
We wanted something that
was built for security
from the ground up, applying
all of Google's best security
practices and tooling to it.
And we also wanted to
further be able to sandbox
this thing itself, to make
it an even stronger security
boundary.
There's one of these user space
VMMs for every virtual machine
that runs on the system.
And each one of these is
itself isolated and sandboxed.
So the idea is, if you
think about this multiple
boundary-type
philosophy, if a workload
were to break out and
compromise its VMM, that
VMM itself is further
sandboxed and unprivileged,
and wouldn't actually give
them any additional information
without some subsequent second
vulnerability in the host
itself.
But again, something
like, say, Meltdown--
well, now it would mean if
somebody were in the VMM,
they could read through the
Meltdown vulnerability--
all of the memory of the
hosts, including all the memory
of the other virtual
machines in the platform.
That simply won't do.
So we have to apply and think
about a series of mitigations
here.
So what were those mitigations?
The first one was something
that we developed.
An engineer on the Kernel
team at Google, Paul Turner,
developed called Retpoline.
And we'll talk about that
in detail in a minute.
But really, the point I
want to emphasize here
is it was our
familiarity with KVM,
the fact that we
spent so much time
doing vulnerability
discovery and fixing
and attack surface
reduction in KVM,
that allowed us to know
exactly the right places in KVM
that we needed to patch
and apply this Retpoline
fix to address and mitigate that
Spectre variant to that applied
to the Hypervisor.
Likewise, mentioning Meltdown,
there's a mitigation there.
We also had to apply KTPI.
That's Kernel
Page-Table Isolation.
I'll talk about
that in detail here
in the next couple of slides.
But this required
not only for us
to update the operating system
on our host machines, Linux,
but also to coordinate
across the industry,
working with all
operating system vendors
to get all OS images patched
with this type of technology.
And then also there
was that variant one--
that bounds check
overflow-- that
meant going and essentially
working with the compiler team,
working with the
operating system team,
and looking for those
vulnerable gadgets
to excise them and remove them.
So to go a little bit deeper
here even more into Retpoline,
what Retpoline was
was the realization
that, like the
speculative engine that's
racing ahead and
trying to figure out
where things are going to go and
potentially then it could start
leaking bits based
on branch movement
of the speculative engine,
we actually could trick that.
We actually could trap it into
essentially an infinite loop
that would grab that
speculative engine
and basically make it realize,
well, there's actually really
no interesting
branch here at all
for it to speculate past
and essentially trap it in.
And then when it came time
to actually really execute
past this branch,
we could self-modify
a little bit of that code
and then open up that.
And the real execution when the
real instructions were issued
would actually then go
past and go beyond it.
So it's this captive
behavior that
actually is what makes this
Retpoline invention work.
The other nice
property about this
is it has very little
impact on performance.
We can't just, and we don't want
to just turn off speculation
across the board, because the
performance of most modern CPUs
would be impacted dramatically.
But what we can do is
we can very selectively
surgically insert this into
those vulnerable branch points
and ensure that the speculative
engine won't leak information
across those.
Shifting back over to this
other thing, Kernel Page Table
Isolation, KPTI.
This was some technology
that was derived
from Kaiser research into--
essentially you can
think of this as--
what we've been
doing for many years
is having a single page table
for both user space and kernel
addresses.
And what that meant is that
if you are in user space,
normally if you try to
address the kernel memory--
high memory above
a certain address--
there would be a page fault.
Can't do that, right?
Page table entry says, well,
this part of the memory address
is for user space.
This part is for privilege
for supervisor for the kernel.
And the problem is that Meltdown
just blows right past that.
So what we had to do is go ahead
and take the hit to say, OK,
well, we've been doing
this single page table
strategy in operating
systems for decades
for performance reasons.
Because whenever you
switch page tables,
you have to flush all
the past translations
and start over from scratch.
And if you're switching back and
forth between user and kernel,
that's really inefficient.
Really slows things down.
But conveniently
a few years back,
modern CPUs started to introduce
this idea of a tag TLB.
This is a way to divide
up that translation buffer
so that you can have--
essentially translations
remain in the buffer
between different page tables.
Well now, rather than
switching from one page table
to another page table and having
to flush everything and then
rebuild all those
translations again--
really slow process--
I actually get to
leave them in the TLB.
And then when I switch address
space to address space,
I just switch back and forth
between those translations.
They remain resident, and I
don't have to flush them out.
So now with this in place then,
I can split up my page tables.
And that means now that
user mode can't actually
meltdown through to any other
addresses other than its own,
because there are no kernel
translations available to it.
It actually has to take
the full transition, which
stops the meltdown problem.
And again, thanks
to this tag TLB,
PCID is one particular
implementation--
the process or
context ID feature--
really speed things up.
Again, this also ended up having
minimal performance impact.
So I just talked
about the things
that we did to
patch on the hosts--
this platform, this
infrastructure.
It was also important
to make sure
that the operating
systems that run
on top of this infrastructure,
to inside these VMs, themselves
were also patched.
And so this was very
much a industry.
Everyone having to
work together to have
this ready to go in time for
the announcement when it became
public.
And this was a collaboration--
a collaboration
that was driven by very
experienced vulnerability
responders like
Google and connections
and through with the
rest of the industry.
So now I've talked about this.
Then how do we actually
get this out in production?
And in particular, get
this out in production
before the world knew
about it, without actually
sort of tipping off
what was going on?
So this is another technology we
have at Google, underlying the
Google Compute Engine
called Live Migration.
Live Migration technology in
many virtualization platforms,
including KVM and our
purpose-built VMM,
that allow you to move
the entire contents
of one virtual machine from one
physical host over to another.
And importantly, do
so without actually
disrupting the workload.
You don't have to restart
the operating system.
You don't have to
restart the workload.
You don't even have to
reconnect existing sessions.
Quick overview of
how this works--
you take a virtual machine, you
start to copy all of its memory
over to another
physical host machine,
and essentially you're
trying to reconstitute
that VM over there.
So eventually over time, you
get all the memory copied over.
But there's always
constant memory churn,
because the VMs are left
running the entire time you're
doing this.
But eventually in time, you
get most of the memory states
seem to cross, and there's
a short blackout period
where you have to pause
this virtual machine, get
the last little bit of
memory in CPU state,
and device state moved over
to the other reconstitution
version of that virtual machine.
Restart it over there, resteer
all the network connections,
and then let it go again.
And we're able to do
this in just an order
of milliseconds operation, with
very minimal impact, or really
no noticeable workload
impact at all.
And in fact, this is a process.
This is a system that we apply
and we do regularly at Google--
to patch the host operating
system, to patch the VMM,
to apply microcode updates
to the host machine.
And so as a process
of doing this,
we're able to essentially
move all the workloads off
of a physical machine, patch
that host machine for whatever
needs to be done for servicing
or for security reasons,
restart that, move VMs back,
and essentially just shuffle
through an entire
zone within GCE
and roll out these
patches-- these updates.
Again, without the
workloads being impacted,
are customers really even being
aware that this is happening?
Amazingly then
with this in place,
is we were able to apply these
patches in the host for Spectre
and Meltdown over the course
of the month of December
without anyone noticing.
And not just for GC--
we actually did this
across the entire Google fleet
to make sure things like Gmail
and G Suite and Search and
Docs and everything else also
had all of these
patches in place.
And it's kind of
interesting to think about.
A system that starts and
runs four billion containers
a week was able to be
patched for these issues
without anyone noticing
or realizing it
was happening over
the course of a month.
I've talked about the technology
that made this possible,
but also, it took people--
took people and process as well.
The way that we often
operate with Google
is sort of as a volunteer
firefighter type model,
where there's a major issue.
OK, we have to do
something about this.
Let's pull together people that
are experts in their field,
whether it be compilers or
virtualization or operating
systems or CPU design, as
well as cross discipline.
It requires communication
and coordination and response
and marketing, PR--
everyone has to come together
to make this actually work.
And this is not the
only time we do this.
We do this quite regularly.
I'm talking about one
particular incident here.
I'll talk about another
in just a minute.
But essentially, I
would say that it's
this relationship-- it's these
connections that we have that
really make this process work.
And the end result
is, as I mentioned,
we were able to patch Google
for Spectre and Meltdown
without anyone being
affected, and without anyone
realizing it was happening.
And this is a proven process--
one that essentially
we've established now
can work against this new
class of vulnerability--
Spectre and Meltdown
type things.
And it's one that we've
proven in production.
If you want to read
more information
about the actual details,
go far more detail--
I could spend an hour
talking about each one
of these different
variants alone.
I've got the links here to the
more information about that.
Definitely recommend
reading that.
And now I'm going to
transition to talk
about another interesting
incident that happened.
This was a 2014 App
Engine attempted breakout.
And we'll talk a little
bit about, again, somehow
this technology applied and
helped to manage and mitigate
this.
Also a little bit of what it
looked like from the inside.
And then how all of our
processes and people
had then come together.
So quick background.
Some context here.
In 2014, a security
researcher, Adam Gadawak,
expert in finding issues with
the Java virtual machine--
finding ways for Java code
to break out of its sandbox--
started to actively do
research on Google App Engine.
What is App Engine?
App Engine is a managed
application platform
that allows users to
deploy code to Google.
Whether it's Php, Python, Go,
Java, we take and host that,
and you don't have to think
about the actual infrastructure
underneath that.
Well, that Java part is
interesting to a Java security
researcher, and he wanted
to understand just how
strong that Java boundary was.
And in fact, we sandbox,
as I mentioned before,
to make sure that the
attack surface is reduced,
layer underneath whatever
the thing is that we
rely on the sandboxes
is tightly locked down.
But again, I mentioned
the two-boundary rule.
So whereas the Java VM was
a boundary in the system,
it wasn't the only boundary.
And so walking through the
sequence of what happened
and what this looked like--
the researcher poking
around the platform,
trying to look at how
we were structuring
how things were done, and
where the boundaries were--
whether his experience
and knowledge in Java
would apply here as well.
Started to poke and
started to poke.
What that looked like from our
point of view is on December 5,
we saw a lot of interesting
alerts and a lot of things
started to light up.
Like, somebody is actually
doing something very active
against the platform.
Something somewhere, maybe where
they shouldn't necessarily be.
We didn't know who it
was, what they were doing,
or why they were doing
this, but we definitely
knew something was a
serious, major issue.
So we froze those instances.
We suspended the account to
look at this, understanding
exactly what was going on.
And so what was going on is
we were depending on the Java
virtual machine as
a first security
boundary in App Engine.
We were relying on
that to constrain
the behavior of the programs
that were deployed so they
couldn't do things like
issue arbitrary system calls
or run arbitrary
binaries on the host.
And we'd gone through
and done a lot
of meticulous work
in the Java VM
itself to reduce
that attack surface
and apply these restrictions.
But it wasn't something that
the Java VM was actually really
originally ever designed for.
And so it was a process
that we had to apply and add
onto these things.
And the security researcher was
finding weaknesses and flaws
in that boundary.
What it highlighted to
us is the challenge--
the issues around relying on the
Java VM as a security boundary.
It helped to motivate
the development
of stronger sandboxing
technology at Google.
But the other thing
that was happening here,
and this was the interesting
part, is the next day--
so December 6--
the security researcher went
onto the full disclosure
security mailing list
and said, hey everybody,
I've been doing research
on Google App Engine.
I think I may have poked
a little bit too far
and gotten a little
too aggressive,
because I got shut down.
I got detected and
shut down right away.
And that was the moment.
And that was actually the
point at which we realized, OK.
Well actually, now we
know who was doing this
and what their motivation was.
Maybe they should
come and talk to us.
Maybe we should work together
on fixing these vulnerabilities.
Because what they
actually had done is,
they'd broken out
of one sandbox,
but they had landed it right
back into another sandbox--
and a sandbox that wasn't Java.
Two distinct, different types
of sandboxes-- different
technologies,
different skill sets,
different vulnerabilities
required to get through.
But it was a place where
we could monitor and see
very anomalous behavior to
respond and shut that down.
And that moves into new
technology and new sandboxing
technology that we developed--
something called gVisor.
gVisor is a sandbox
technology that
was derived from research
into operating system level
virtualization.
When we think of
virtualization, we usually
think either really low-level,
like machine VMs emulating CPU
and device behavior, or we think
about these language-level VMs,
like Java.
The idea with gVisor
is actually there's
a maybe even more efficient
way to sandbox and isolate
applications, by emulating
system-called behavior.
And so essentially, we're
emulating an operating system--
not a machine, not a
language, but an OS
at the system-call layer.
And in fact, with the
development of this now,
we're able to run the
majority of untrusted code
at Google on top of gVisor.
And it's significantly
more efficient than trying
to fall back to
running everything
into large virtual machines.
We open sourced that
earlier this year.
If you're interested to
learn more about gVisor,
we have an entire talk on
that coming on Thursday.
I'd definitely recommend
going to take a look at that.
Or go up onto GitHub,
and you can take a look
at the source code for it.
So the end result is with
this series of technology
and our incident
response process
and the multi-layers
of sandboxing,
we're able to detect and
constrain and confine
an attempted breakout
of App Engine
by a noted security expert.
The other thing about this
is, in doing so in such a way
that they were still confined--
didn't impact anybody.
Didn't impact other
customers, or other user data.
The other thing
that this leads into
is the Vulnerability
rewards program at Google,
and why this interaction
and outreach with security
researchers is so important.
We ended up developing this
relationship with this security
researcher, and to find and fix
more issues within App Engine
so that customers and
users could be safe.
To talk a little bit more
about the Vulnerability rewards
program, I'll hand
it back over to Andy.
ANDY CHANG: Thanks, Brandon.
So as Brandon alluded to, the
Vulnerabilty rewards program
was something that, once
we had the connection
with the security
researcher, we were
able to pull them into that
and engage within that.
And to step back
a bit, the purpose
of the Vlunerability
rewards program at Google
is really around turning
what is traditionally
an adversarial relationship
between security researchers
and software developers
and software providers
into something that's
collaborative and creates value
and wins for the security
researcher themselves,
for the software provider,
and really most importantly,
for the end customer.
As security researchers
get rewarded,
both in terms of recognition and
actual financial compensation
for their energy, for their
ingenuity, for their interest
in digging into things deeply,
and us as software providers
get the benefit of
that additional set
of eyes working actively
to improve and find
flaws in the software.
And as I said,
again, end customers
benefit because the quality
of software goes up.
The Vulnerability
rewards program at Google
was started in 2010,
over eight years ago.
And today we've paid out almost
$12 million in rewards to that.
So in addition to the
recognition-- and some folks
do this for recognition,
security researchers
do this to just improve
underlying software,
and some do do it
for the benefits
of the financial reward.
But as we look at it,
it really promotes
things like ethical hacking.
And over the time, as
the program has evolved,
we've expanded the
program to cover
not just Google and Cloud,
but Android and other services
at Google.
Each have their own parts of the
Vulnerability rewards program.
Also as times evolve,
we've continued
to increase also the
financial rewards tied
to particular vulnerabilities
that are found.
Just recently we
elevated the reward
found for sandbox escapes
from $20,000 to $31,337.
And if you want to know
where that number comes from,
you can talk to me
after this session.
So once we're able to
bring this together,
the security researcher,
and therefore
able to really understand
what was going on
and resolve the
incidents, both we
were able to then go mitigate
the issues on App Engine,
and then proceed
forward and start
looking for the next incident.
Now, to talk a little bit about
that-- we've talked about,
and Brandon's covered a lot
of the technologies, process,
and people around
Spectre and Meltdown.
And in both Spectre and
Meltdown, and the 2014 App
Engine breakout,
the overall process
of how we do detection response
at Google was the same.
So as an overview, we
have experts in SOCs
around the world that follow
the clock on a 24/7 basis.
From an overall
standpoint, when we
think about the problem
with detection response,
we actually break
it into two parts.
First is the underlying
pre-fail component.
So how do we
proactively understand
how to assess our
own attack surface--
our own potential risks
and vulnerabilities.
What are the things
that are being
done to specify using policy--
the things, the
behavior that should be?
How do we actually
build protections?
Like we talked about on
the two-boundary rule--
the sandboxing that
inherently build
a structure that's difficult for
the aggressors to get through.
And in a lot of ways,
the two-boundary rule--
the defense in-depth-- is trying
to flip the story from a case
where traditionally,
attackers have the benefit.
They're hiding within
a number of signals.
And as a defender, there's a
needle in a haystack problem,
trying to find them in
the midst of everything.
And flipping this in a
multi-boundary situation
to where the attacker
has to be really careful,
because they have
multiple layers
they actually have to
get through and try
to escape detection.
And that's trying to balance
out that attacker/defender
relationship.
In addition to the pre-fail
pieces and the protections,
we then obviously have
monitoring logging,
which allow us to both
understand if the pre-fail
configurations and
specifications we've let drift,
as well as to handle
the post-fail case--
to actually detect when
there is an actual incident.
And as Brandon outlined
before in the two examples,
go through the
rest of the process
to bring in that volunteer
firefighter approach-- bring
in experts around the
different aspects of Google
to address these things.
And when we think about the
post-fail detection response
process, it is also multistaged.
There's the process of detection
itself in the signals database
that we've built out
to be able to do this,
the alerting, the actual
response itself, which
can be either straightforward
or significantly complex
when something's at the scale
of Spectre and Meltdown.
And then communications.
Communications internally,
communications with the product
teams, communications to
customers, communications
to other entities that are
involved in the situation.
And then ultimately for
us, the learning feedback.
So both at a human
level, a process level,
and also machine
learning technology
level so that we're better.
And so that each
step, each next thing,
we can further reduce
the time to detection
and further reduce the
time to mitigation.
So our security teams
have the benefit
of very integrated
forensics set of tools,
whether it's to do live memory
forensics or disc forensics,
timeline analysis, and tie
all these different threads
together.
And also the automation
to do that at scale.
We've actually open-sourced
a number of these tools
so that our customers and
the community in general
can benefit.
The folks of you who
are in the industry
are probably familiar with
Grr, Turbinia, Recall--
these are a number of the
tools we use every day--
Timesketch.
These are all now available
on Git as open source tooling
that you can use yourself
to also build out
your forensics toolkit.
And one of the other
things is, as probably you
might anticipate, Google is
one of the most targeted sites
across the world.
So from that benefit,
our security teams
have to be ever vigilant.
And there's the classic
problem of garrison fatigue.
If you're vigilant
on standing on guard
for an extended
period of time and you
don't get many actual
incidents or pieces
with these systems
that are protecting us,
how do you still
retain that vigilance?
So we have an active culture
within Google of red teaming--
of Google on Google.
And that's the key thing.
And again, uses
the same philosophy
we use in our instant response.
It's a volunteer
firefighter approach.
So we get some of
the key experts
to go hack sometimes and
attack their own code--
other folks' code
within the products.
And that kind of both energy
and spirit, as well as
that really putting the highest
level expertise and visibility
on particular
types of red teams,
enables us ourselves to quickly
find vulnerabilities and flaws
in the system.
Though we don't
pay out of the VRP
for our own internal employees,
to much to their unhappiness.
So if you look at the overall
threat detection pipeline
once we see something,
you see that cycle
of looking at logs-- observing.
Then actually
orientating in terms
of figuring out
from the security
analytics what's going on.
Actually making decisions about
from the underlying pieces,
what to do.
And ultimately taking
those remediations.
The top part of that is
technology and process centric.
So we have the advantage of
large scale data ingestion
pipelines, threat direct
detection pipelines.
Some of those
things you guys have
seen as a part of
Google Cloud platform.
BigQuery is something
that we use internally
as well to do a lot of our
signals and logs processing.
And then from the
ingestion standpoint,
the ability to really take in
and handle all that scale data.
The last point I want to
reemphasize what Brandon talked
about as well, is you could
have the greatest technology,
you can have the
greatest process--
you also need really, really
strong people in this space.
We are very fortunate
to have the advantage
of a lot of experienced
folks in this space.
And as I think you've
heard throughout this talk,
given all the different
aspects of some of these
vulnerabilities, especially
something like Spectre
and Meltdown, the
multi-disciplinary nature
of the skillset needed--
readily available in-house
at Google to address things,
whether its processor
architecture, compilers, OS,
virtualization,
underlying hardware--
all those pieces
can come together.
And then, an equally
important thing
is, as one of the
largest targets, also
one of the biggest contributors
to security for the community,
we have tier one relationships
with other similarly skilled
organizations and entities.
And that allows us
to be in the loop
for a lot of these discussions.
So as I mentioned previously,
the SOC that we use
is 24/7 around the world, and
the underlying teams really
include not only the
subject matter experts,
but the mix of security
engineers, analysts, and also
forensics experts.
And so the bottom
half of this loop,
then, is really around
the human aspect of it.
Top half being
technology and process.
We also need the humans to
actually make the decisions--
the right decisions, as
Brandon talked about.
Where to put mitigations
like Retpoline,
and where to actually do
those with lowest impact
on overall performance.
So to summarize, given something
at the scale of Spectre
and Meltdown, which again,
were fundamental flaws in most
modern microprocessors that
impacted the entire industry,
for someone who is a Google
customer, it was a nonevent.
Customers didn't
have to do anything.
Customers were not impacted.
And that really is the nature of
some of the security and design
infrastructure that
we've put in place,
and the ongoing aspiration
of how the team works.
And then to summarize
then as we've
talked about through
this, in order
to achieve that type
of result, we really
do need proven technology,
process, and people.
And it starts with the core
philosophy around Google
that Brandon and I both talked
about-- this defense in depth.
No single point of failure.
That at least two-boundary rule
built across all the services
and all the components
within Google,
where we are very fortunate
to have that ability
to have an end-to-end
ownership of the hardware
and software, many a
things purpose-built,
so then also that deep
understanding of the underlying
technology.
So to know where to put
mitigations and fixes where
they have the highest impact on
the actual security instance,
and the lowest impact on
end customer performance.
As I think Diane highlighted
in the keynote, the consistency
of our infrastructure--
homogeneity,
the kind of ability for us
to manage our infrastructure
in the commonly-used phrase,
"as cattles, not pets,"
so that you can have
automation, scalability,
and you can do
patching, detection--
all of these at scale.
And then really, the proven
response and remediation
process--
at the end of the
day, that experienced
multi-disciplinary team.
So we designed
the solutions that
addressed the flaws found
in Spectre and Meltdown
so that they could be
mitigated across all of Google
and for all Google's customers.
And we applied patches to
the full fleet of Google,
including GC, in
one single month,
before these
attacks were public.
With again, no
effort from customers
and no noticeable
impact on them.
So with that, I'd like
to conclude the talk
and invite Brandon back up so
we can take some questions.
I think there is a
floor mic at the end
if you guys have any questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]